so
when i talk about specific knowledge i
talk about what i'm basically saying is
figure out what is it that you were
doing as a kid or as a teenager almost
effortlessly
that you didn't even consider a skill
but people around you notice like your
mother would know your best friend
growing up with no and to give you
examples of what could be it could be
sales skills it could be that you were
just musically talented and you just had
the ability to pick up any instrument uh
it could be that you had an obsessive
personality so you would dive into
things and learn them very quickly it
could be that you had a love for science
fiction so you were into sci-fi you were
into reading which means that you can
absorb lots of knowledge very quickly it
could have been
you're playing a lot of games so you
actually understand game theory pretty
well uh it could even be you know you
were out there gossiping and digging
into your friend network and that might
make you into a very interesting kind of
journalist but
a specific knowledge is sort of this
weird combination of unique traits from
your dna combined with your unique
upbringing and your response to it
and it's almost baked into your
personality and your identity and then
you can hone it so for example i love to
read and i love technology so i learn
very very quickly and i get bored fast
just like one of the commentators
mentioned i have that same issue so if i
had gone into
a profession that required me to tunnel
down for 20 years into the same topic it
wouldn't work but because i'm in venture
investing which requires me to come up
to speed very very quickly on new
technologies and it kind of rewards
getting bored because there's all the
new technology coming along to evaluate
it matches up pretty well with my
specific knowledge and skill sets
yeah so learning to sell let's talk
about sales skills
because this goes into specific
knowledge
sales skills are a form of specific
knowledge really good sales people i
think
it you can be trained so it's not to say
you can't learn it
but
really there's such a thing as a natural
in sales and you run into them all the
time in the industry that i'm in and
when you meet someone who is a natural
at sales you just know that they're
amazing and they're really good at what
they do
that is a form of specific knowledge now
obviously they learned that somewhere
but they didn't learn that in a
classroom setting they learned that
probably in their childhood in a
schoolyard they learned it negotiating
with their parents maybe some of its
genetic component in their dna
so and you can improve it you can read
robert caldini you can go to a sales
training seminar you can do door-to-door
scales which is brutal but will train
you very quickly
so you can definitely improve your sales
skills sales skills but
a lot of sales is this specific
knowledge that you learn just by doing
especially at a very early age i think
people underestimate maybe how
valuable their specific knowledge is or
how unique they are um
that's something that is kind of
we all have you know self-doubts and
insecurities and we are like you know
we're used to walking down the street
and feeling not too dissimilar from ten
thousand other people that we saw these
success stories and it feels so
maybe far away and like those people
were so different than us um but it's
not like i think everyone has something
really valuable to bring and can
productize themselves in an interesting
way and everyone's story can be
valuable to someone um anything
is a hell of a drug yeah
it's a hell of a drug and i would say
like
no matter how small you start like jack
again has an amazing cure for this his
goal is just like make one dollar on the
internet just go sell one thing to one
person for one dollar and you will feel
different it will start that snowball
and you kind of slowly build up the
confidence you know you got to start at
the tutorial level maybe um but you're
going to keep building that confidence
and you're going to slowly kind of
grow your way into finding your audience
and find your way through that maze and
just taking that first step will give
you the confidence to take the second to
take the third um
but but you you know whoever is
listening to this you are more unique
and valuable than you think you are
and everyone is kind of an incredible
combination of their genetics and their
experience and their perspectives and
their beliefs and everyone is unique and
everyone has
some sort of skill or insight that they
can bring to other people if you can
learn it and package it the right way
and just
see what people respond to that you want
to bring to them um
so that's
you know that's probably even before the
kind of
logistical stumbling blocks is just the
belief that there's something there for
you to do and for you to add value
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you